[संगीत]
खुदा
सो हेलो
तो ठीक है पर थोड़ा सा आज आज सेशन है वह
शायद थोड़ा सा हैवी हैवी हो सकता है लेकिन
ज्यादा भी हैवी पर नहीं करेंगे मतलब मैं
ज्यादा सीरियस के लिए कर नहीं कर रहा हूं
आज के दिन में तो शायद इतना हैवी ना हो
थोड़ा हैवी लाइट हैवी लाइट का बैलेंस
मैंने बना के रखा है इसके बाद में अब सारे
इसके आज के बाद से थोड़े बहुत रहेंगे वो
थोड़े आपको हैवी हैवी से ग सकते हैं तो आज
से थोड़ा कंसंट्रेशन वगैरा आप लोग का
ज्यादा देखने को मिले तो ज्यादा बढ़िया
रहेगा
ताकि आपको आगे का भी समझ में आएगा उसे
टाइम पर इसीलिए
ग्रुप बाय कमांड के बड़े में
क्या समझते हैं अपन चीजों का ग्रुप करना
अगर ना आपने बहुत ही यार अपने अगर एडमिन
पैनल्स वगैरा देखते हो या कुछ भी एनालाइज
वगैरा देखा हो
की आप लोग
कितने बंदे हैं
इतने जगह से कितने बंदे हैं यह चीज कितने
दोनों में कारी है वह चीज कितनी जन के
डिफरेंस अपन को अलग-अलग टाइप के थ्रू पता
रखते हैं तो उसे कैसे में क्या हो रहा
होता है ना की वो डाटा का ग्रुप बना रहे
थे किसी भी एक चीज को पर्टिकुलर लेक उसे
ग्रुप बना दीजिए जैसे मैंने अभी स्ट्रेट
की वो स्ट्रेट क्या है ग्रुप बना लेते हैं
की अरेना ये ये
ग्रुप के जो बंदे हैं कितने हैं उसे ग्रुप
के बंदे कितने हैं तीसरी गंदे कितने हैं
अपने कॉलेज सिस्टम की तरह है भाई देखो
अपने स्कूल के अंदर तो क्या राहत था ना की
सारे सारे अपने दोस्त होते थे अपन कसम भी
खाता थे जो इंडियन सर्च बट कॉलेज में
कस्टमर तोड़ देते हैं अपना अलग-अलग ग्रुप
बन जाता है
और हर ग्रुप में कितने
चीजें हैं वो अपन ग्रुप ओपन कर सकते हैं
तो भी ए जाएगा वैसे भी ए जाएगा
कल का नोटपैड है मैं वो भी खोल लेट हूं
ठीक है तो मैं थोड़ा सा इसको अच्छा लाइन
कर देता हूं
कनेक्ट करने के लिए हम लिखेंगे यहां पर
कनेक्ट
सिस्टम
थोड़ा मुझे भी ऐसा लगा चाहिए की यार
गिविंग सम एफर्ट्स सो आई अलसो वांट सम
आउटपुट बैक ना तो वही बात है
की अपन ने कल एक डिलीट कमांड अच्छी थी अपन
ने ठीक है
भाई नाराज हो जाएंगे तुमसे अच्छा है
और बोलो
तो अभी अपन क्या करेंगे
कितने स्टेट से कितने लोग हैं तो वह कैसे
करेंगे
ठीक है ना प्राइमरी किसी भी करोगे तो कोई
दिक्कत वाली बात है किसी से करोगे तो कोई
दिक्कत वाली बात नहीं बस उनको आउटपुट
अच्छे से चाहिए इसके लिए बड़ी नल वाला मत
लेने की कोशिश करना
ठीक है सिलेक्ट स्टेट अकाउंट
करना है ठीक है नर्सरी स्टेट और काउंट
स्टार्ट फ्रॉम एम्पलाई
ग्रुप बनाना है ग्रुप बाय स्टेट
ठीक है अब देखो इसका क्या मतलब हुआ ना
पेपर बताओ
[संगीत]
ठीक है तो यहां पे क्या होगा ना सबसे पहले
क्या होता है ना अपना यहां पर लिखना राहत
है अपन को सिलेक्ट तो अपना राहत ही है ठीक
है ना मैंने कहा था सॉलिड बहुत ज्यादा
बड़ी चीज है
अभी दो-तीन दिन और अपन को सिलेक्ट के अंदर
ही बिताने हैं ठीक है ना मैंने कहा था 2
दिन लेकिन नहीं शायद तीन से कर दिन ग रहे
हैं बट कोई बात नहीं अपन को चीज अंदर तक
समझनी है ऐसे अपन ऊपर ऊपर वाले कम नहीं
करते हैं अपन ने एकदम अंदर वाले कम करते
हैं
डबल मीनिंग था लेकिन ठीक है दोनों जगह पे
तो सबसे पहले ना यहां पर एक्सप्रेशन ठीक
है ना जो जी चीज का अपन ग्रुप बना रहे हैं
ना जी कलम को हम ग्रुप बना रहे हैं वही
यहां पर डालेगा
ठीक है
वो तो बताना ही पड़ेगा फिर ग्रुप बाय यह
अपना क्लोज है
अब बाकी फिर जी अपुन को कलम से ग्रुप करने
का है वह कलम का नहीं तो अभी क्या होगा ना
स्टेट वाइस सबको ग्रुप करेगा और उसके अंदर
का चीज़ काउंट करेगा ठीक है ना यह कमांड
पूरा यह करेगा देखना है
ठीक है तो सबसे पहले गुजरात ऊपर गुजरात है
जैसे मैंने गुजरात किया गुजरात में कितने
बंदे हैं लेकिन मीत नहीं भाई अपने गुजरात
से हैं बाकी और कोई यहां पर गुजरात से
नहीं दिखे रहा है ठीक है
उसके बाद राजस्थान से राजस्थान के
123 बंदे अपने राजस्थान से तो अपने यहां
पर राजस्थान में तीन ए गया यहां पर एक ए
गया ठीक है
तो वही कम करें
सैलरी इसका की हर स्टेट मतलब स्टेट वाइस
में लोगों को कितना मेरे जब से पैसा जा
रहा है क्या देखो मेरे को बढ़िया आदमी
बढ़िया आप लोगों को पता होगा बिजनेसमैन
मैंडेट आदमी वह हर जगह पैसे का ही देखा है
इसलिए मैं है ना ये एम्पलाइज टेबल से बाहर
नहीं जाता ना तो सैलरी वाला जो है ना मैं
उसके आसपास घूम रहा हूं मैं बढ़िया आदमी
हूं भाई ठीक है ना मेरे को बहुत दिक्कत है
पैसे पैसे वाला चीज ठीक है तो मैं यहां पे
सम करूंगा अपना सैलरी को
ठीक है ना सिलेक्ट और सम करना है सैलरी का
स्टेट वाइस ग्रुप बाय मैं स्ट्रेट लिखा था
स्टेट वाइस साड़ी सैलरी इसका सम होगा मतलब
गुजरात का गुजराती लेकर राजस्थान के कितने
लोगों का सैलरी का महाराष्ट्र के कितने
लोग हैं कैसे समझेगा दिल्ली के कितने लोग
उनके साथ निकले
फंक्शन क्या है वो मैंने पहले ही बताया है
ठीक है
गुजरात के अंदर अपना एक ही आएगा तो 80
हजार के जूते इसने खरीद लिया है आपने ठीक
है
ये एक दो तीन इन तीनों का समूह ठीक है
दिल्ली वालों को भी दिया जाता है ऐसे नहीं
करने का
ठीक है ना ये चीजों को ग्रुप बनाकर उनके
अंदर फंक्शंस को अप्लाई कर रहे हैं की यार
मुझे ना जैसे आपने
कोई भी अगर वेबसाइट की आप एडमिन
देखा हो या फिर कुछ भी एनालिसिस देखा हो
तो उसके अंदर अपन को ऐसा ही ग्रुप का ही
इस्तेमाल
तो यही पीछे बैक हैंड में चल रहा होता है
ठीक है यही कमांड पीछे चल रही होती है जो
आपका जो वेबसाइट बनाते हो वेबसाइट का जो
आप अगर एचपी या जैंगो मैंगो यहां पे
फ्लैशबैक जिसकी भी आप कम कर रहे हो तो वो
आपका यही पीछे बैक साइड में कम कर रहा है
ठीक है
रुपए को लेकर
इसको मत लगाओ भाई
उसे कलम के अंदर जो आम चीज होगी
वहां पे जाके विजिट कर लगा ठीक है
तो इसने दो का दो का ग्रुप बना दिया फिर
जाके जो अपन को यहां पर फंक्शन एग्जीक्यूट
करने का है वो ओपन नहीं है
वो वाला फंक्शन एग्जीक्यूट कर देगा जो
वाला फंक्शन लगा रखा है
अगर आप पहले कलेक्शन में नहीं थे तो मैं
ये आपको सजेस्ट करूंगा की आप पिस्टल भी
देख कर आए
चीज समझ पाएंगे
ठीक है अब देखो
ग्रुप भाई का इस्तेमाल करते हैं तो वहां
पर वेयर नहीं लगता है वहां पर हेविंग लगता
है
ना
तो वेयर यहां पर मत लगाना
लगता है तो यार ऐसा नहीं होता है किसी
किसी चीज में जैसा ग्रुप बाय जब ग जाता है
यहां पर तो मतलब अपना वेयर वाला चीज कम
नहीं करेगा इसकी जगह
मतलब कुछ भी ऊपर नीचे नहीं है मुझे खुद को
नहीं पता इन लोगों
ने रखा है ठीक है
ज्यादा सूट करेगा
सिलेक्ट करो
एम्पलाई टेबल में से और ग्रुप बना स्टेट
का जिसके पास में ये कंडीशन है
हेविंग मतलब जिनके पास में
तो शायद मेरी गलती इंग्लिश के साथ किया बट
कोई बात नहीं अपन को उतना दीप मतलब
उन्होंने जो किया यार अपन को बिल्कुल कुछ
आइडिया नहीं है अपने हिसाब से ठीक है ना
बट जो चीज हैं जो चीज उनका अपना अपन को
जानना चाहिए
डेवलपर बन जाएंगे तो अपन खुद का भी एक
निकाल देंगे और निकाल जैसा फिर आप अपने
हिसाब से लगाना अपने जो चेंज करने बट ये
जो क्वेरीज है
अगर से ही रहेगी आप खुद की लैंग्वेज निकाल
लो तो अलग बात है तो मुझे टाइम भी अगर अपन
किसी प्लेटफॉर्म में डिपेंडेंट कम कर रहे
हैं तो अपन को उनके हिसाब से चलना पड़ेगा
मतलब यहां पे हेविंग क्यों ग रहा है यहां
पे बियर क्यों नहीं ग रहा है ठीक है अब
देखो अगर मैं चाहूं
मैं सैलरी
जिनका जो 80 हजार से ऊपर का सैलरी है मतलब
सिर्फ वही स्टेट दिखे जिन स्टेटस का सम
अपना 80000 से ऊपर हो 80000 से ऊपर हो ठीक
है
मैं यहां पर शेर लिख दूंगा हेविंग
सम
सैलरी ग्रेटर दें 80 एयर
महाराष्ट्र
राजस्थान दिल्ली अपने कंडीशन के हिसाब से
सम सैलरी का
सम सैलरी
एक यह भी तरीका है अगर अपन को सिर्फ
अकाउंट चाहिए क्या कितने जनों को मैं दे
रहा हूं अपना 80 हजार से ऊपर अपना स्टर के
टोटल के हिसाब से
तो मैं एक यह भी अप्रोच फॉलो कर सकता हूं
बट अगर मुझे सबका सैलरी का तो मैं ऐसे
जाऊंगा ठीक है अगर मैं सैलरी के सामने
काउंट स्टार्ट करके लिखूंगा ठीक है ना वो
यहां पर मैं एक बार फिर से समझता हूं मुझे
ग रहा शायद आप लोगों के ऊपर से ज्यादा
रहेगा फिर से इसको समझने की कोशिश करता
हूं सिलेक्ट करना सिलेक्ट किया आपने स्टेट
और सैलरी
का सम अपना सीधा
17000 निकाला ठीक है बट ये जो 60 हजार है
और 80 जा रहे हैं ये अपना दोनों 80 हजार
से ऊपर नहीं है 80 हजार से नीचे है तो ये
ये और ये यहां पर नहीं आने से बात ये
दोनों चीज यहां पर आनी चाहिए तो वही इसमें
ए गया रहेगा
ठीक है अब क्या सीन है की अगर अपन इस वाले
के अंदर देखें तो उसने ये क्या सिलेक्ट
किया स्टेट और उसके अंदर की चीज इसमें
काउंट कारी है
एम्पलाई टेबल में से और ग्रुप बना है
स्टेट के हिसाब से अब स्टेट के हिसाब से
ग्रुप बनाया है तो कंडीशन लगेगी
हेविंग अपनी कंडीशन लगेगी और कंडीशन अपना
लगा है की जिनकी जिन स्टेट की सैलरी का सम
ठीक है ना क्योंकि देखो स्ट्रेट वाइस सपना
चल रहा है तो ये जो भी फंक्शन यहां पे
अप्लाई होगा वो फंक्शन अपना अप्लाई होगा
अपने स्टेट के ऊपर मतलब जो अपने आप पर
उसे ग्रुप के ऊपर ठीक है ना तो ये उसे
ग्रुप का सैलरी का सम निकलेगा
और चेक करेगा
सिर्फ उन्हें वाले स्टेटस को यह यहां पर
शो करेगा
तो सब कुछ अपना उसे ग्रुप के ऊपर ही होगा
ठीक है ना कोई तीसरी चीज के ऊपर
इंप्लीमेंट नहीं होगी
चलो अपना हेविंग
टोटल सैलरी अगर मैं लिखना चाहूं तो मैं
यहां पर लिखूंगा सम सैलरी एस
यहां पर लिखूंगा मैं ये लगा के टूटल सैलरी
लगा दिया
ठीक है तो यह अपने ग्रुप के बड़े में
कैसे कम करता है क्या होता है ग्रुप में
और अपना उसके अंदर कंडीशन कैसे डालते हैं
ग्रुप भाई के अंदर समझ में आया की नहीं
सबको प्लीज एक बार चाट में
अच्छी बात है
ओनली
ठीक है अब अगर मैं चाहता हूं की मुझे
सिर्फ वही बंदों के नाम दिखे जिनका सैलरी
अपना
80000 से लेकर 90 हजार के बीच में हो
ठीक है ना जिसके अंदर हनी चाहिए ठीक है
तो उसके लिए मैं यहां पर क्या लिखूंगा
सिलेक्ट स्टार
लगा रहा हूं वहां पर आप कलम के नाम भी देख
सकते हो जब कलम का नाम चाहते हो यह मैं
पिछले दोनों से किस का रहा हूं आज भी का
रहा हूं
स्टार लगाना पड़ेगा
ऐसा करो तो ऐसा हो रहा है यह ऐसा क्यों हो
रहा रहेगा प्यार दूसरे चीज दाल के डॉग अगर
ऐसे करके देखा हूं फिर ऐसा हो रहा है तो
शायद ही इसका ऐसा हो सकता है ट्राई करते
रहोगे तो आप खुद के कॉन्सेप्ट खुद ही
बिल्ड कर लोग ऐसे धीरे-धीरे कर करके ना
आपको मतलब किसी भी चीज की जरूर नहीं
पड़ेगी अगर आपकी ट्रेन ट्राई अटेंड ट्राई
करते रहते हो अगर आपका अगर आपके पास टाइम
है मतलब यार पढ़ने के टाइम पे बस होना ही
चाहिए तो अगर आप अगर आप टाइम निकाल का रहे
हो इन चीजों के लिए तो आपकी ट्रेन ट्राई
करके देखो चीज एरर्स आएंगे एरर्स एनालाइज
करो और खुद के कॉन्सेप्ट भी बिल्कुल बिल्ड
करो ये खुद के नोट्स का सकते हैं उसको
कॉन्सेप्ट पे से ही होता है सबका आ मतलब @
उसकी जगह पहुंचने हैं जो होता है एक्चुअली
बट आप खुद के खुद के दिमाग में उसे
लैंग्वेज में खुद को आप एक्सप्लेन कर सकते
हो की यार ये इस चक्कर में ऐसा हुआ था तो
वो चीजों को थोड़ा सा ध्यान में रखना
जरूरी है लर्निंग करो किसी भी लैंग्वेज है
किसी भी इसके अंदर अगर आप ऐसा कर रहे हो
तो आप वहां पर एक चीज ट्राई करके देख सकते
हो लेकिन स्टार फ्रॉम
अब मेरा क्वेश्चन था की सैलरी में से मुझे
दिखाना है की ₹80000 से लेकर 90 हजार के
बीच में तीन तीन का सैलरी लाइक करता है
जिसमें अपना 80 हजार दोनों इंक्लूड रहेगा
ठीक है तो मैं लिखूंगा मैं सिलेक्ट फ्रॉम
एम्पलाई
ठीक है अब यहां पर मैं लिखूंगा वेयर
कंडीशन के लिए वेयर अपना सैलरी
बिटवीन
कलम के लिए
लगता है की नहीं तो प्लीज को और ट्री
वेयर इसे बिटवीन 80 हजार
ऑन का है
अल में अपना डाटा
बिटवीन ऑपरेटर क्या कर रहा है यहां पर
कलम का नियम डालेंगे
वीडियो लिखने के बाद
ऑपरेटर के बड़े में आपको ये वाला ऑपरेटर
को ये मैसेज बाद में बताऊंगा आपका टाइम
मिलेगा तो उसे स्क्रीन पे दूंगा लेकिन वही
आज यहां पे कंटिन्यू हो रहा है तो ये मैं
सोचना की मैंने जो कल छोड़ था वो छोड़ के
रख दिया है वो हमें करता हूं कर रहा हूं
ठीक है ना
तो यहां पर मैंने बिटवीन किया अब यहां पे
ना अपन को डालना यहां पर डालना राहत है
लोअर वैल्यू ठीक है
बोरिंग ग रहा था तो इसका मतलब ये थोड़ी की
आपको चीज समझोगे नहीं है वो क्लास देखोगे
ही नहीं
करनी पड़ती है
तो यह अपना बिटवीन
के बड़े में
बता दिया है
डाटा हो तो यह पान कार्ड
चाहिए
एमपी आईडी
इन अमेजॉन
यहां पर जाकर अपने कमांड
से करता हूं
[संगीत]
वह भी कर सकते हैं
आज क्लास के बाद में अगर मैं हर क्लास के
बड़े में
आप मुझे का देना
ये वाला पार्ट्स छोड़ दिया है ठीक है हो
जाएगा
ठीक है ना
लेफ्ट स्क्रीन में
मेरा यहां पर मैं कमांड से करता हूं
पता लगेगा ठीक है ना
मुझे टेस्ट करने के लिए आते हैं तो मुझे
कितना आता है
कितना नहीं ए रहा है कुछ जगह गलत बोल रहे
थे एकदम से गलत तोक डॉग भाई अभी गलत बोल
रहे हो
सॉरी
ऑपरेटर से कीबोर्ड
का चप्पल
अपना
80 हजार है और
90000 उनका दिखाओ
तो इसके अंदर जो पैटर्न है पैटर्न कैसे
पैटर्न है वह पैटर्न भी अपन देखेंगे
समझाया था
संकल्प भाई मैं आपको
आज के लेक्चर समझ में आएंगे ठीक है
वो भी मैसेज डाला था वो एक बार उसको पी कर
दो ताकि इन लोगों को थोड़ा नीचे समझ में ए
जाएगी पैसा देखना करो जरूरी पद जाता है
नेक्स्ट एक्सिस देखने के लिए
देखो मां लो की नहीं यार अगर मेरे पास ही
तो कोई एक ही नाम है
जिसके नाम के स्टार्टिंग में अपना
टाइम लगाओ
नाम लाइक
तो देखो
तो वह चीज यहां पर क्या आपको ऐसा ग रहा हो
की यार आप अपने देखो दोस्तों बेस्ट फ्रेंड
र चुकी है ना बटन उसको नाम पता नहीं होता
तो मैं कैसे सर्च करेगा
यार एम के बाद में कौन सी क्रस्ट थी इसकी
तो उसकी डेटाबेस में दिखे जाएगी हां वही
है इसकी क्राइसिस थी ठीक है अभी किसी वक्त
किस वाले की बात कर रहा था मैं अगर वो
देखा हूं
तो देखो तो एम परसेंट का इस्तेमाल करेगा
ठीक है ना तो अगर मां लो की यार मुझे इतना
मालूम है की यार ना एक बांदा था
जिसके स्टार्टिंग में 2 करैक्टर
कुछ भी था
तो उसे कैसे में क्या कमांड लिखूं यहां पर
सिलेक्ट
स्टार
लगा दिया
जिसके एक नाम के बाद में एक्स लगा हुआ है
ठीक है ना और आगे का मुझे पता नहीं ठीक है
तो मैं यहां पर क्या करूंगा
ठीक है
ना उसका आखरी जो ना नाम का आखिरी या किसी
भी चीज का आखरी उसका ही था ठीक है
ना तो अब देखते हैं इसका
लाइक ऑपरेटर अपना कम आता है
ठीक है
तो चलो ठीक है
10 मिनट का तो मैं उसको बता देता हूं
है ना यहां पर मैंने डाटा देखें हैं यहां
पर ठीक है अब मैं चाहता हूं की यार मुझे
जो रिपीटेड डाटा है वो नहीं दिखे मतलब कोई
में कलम सर्च कर रहा हूं ठीक है ना अब
ओनली उसे उसे सिंगल कलम के अंदर जो
रिपीटेड डाटा है वो ना आए
अगर देखो अगर मैं यहां पर नॉर्मलूंगा
सिलेक्ट
सैलरी फ्रॉम
ठीक है
रिपीट हो रहा है मैं चाहता हूं की रिपीट
डाटा
डिस्टिंक्ट
सैलरी फ्रॉम एम्पलाई मतलब डिफरेंस
हो गया ठीक है
906085805 ठीक है जो डबल टाइम बीता ए रहा
था वो सिंगल टाइम ही हुआ है इसने सीक्वेंस
कैसे कैसे कर्म कैसा हुआ है वो मुझे
बिल्कुल नहीं पता लेकिन जो है वो यही है
ठीक है
तो डस्टिंग कीवर्ड क्या कर रहा है ना की
जो डिप्टी डाटा था उसको सिर्फ एक बार यहां
पर दिखा रहा है
किसी को प्रिया जगह मुझे चाट नहीं बता दो
सिंपल सी है इतनी हैवी नहीं लगी
करण ये भी हो सकता है की आप लास्ट
ठीक है बट एक चीज याद रखना की
कल का जो लेक्चर होगा ना कल कल लेक्चर
थोड़ा सा हैवी सा हो सकता है
इतना भी हैवी नहीं रहेगा मेरे ख्याल से बट
मैं उसके लिए बस एक डेडीकेटेड पुरी क्लास
ही करूंगा ठीक है तो भले ही थोड़ा छोटा
टाइम हो लेकिन आपको समझ में आना चाहिए वह
मटर करता है अभी इस स्टेज में
ठीक है
वह पैराग्राफ
डेट थी
मैं आपको लाइक और प्रिंटर को एक बार अच्छे
से ट्राई करने का है अच्छे से पेटर्न्स
मुझे दिखाओ यहां पर ये कैसे लगता हैं
पैटर्न ठीक है ना और साथ के अंदर जो भी
आजकल रिवाइज करो
ज्यादा हो गया टास्क लेकिन छोटे मोटे
लैंडलाइन
की अच्छी क्लास कैसी थी
बहुत कम लोग डांस कर रहे हैं टेलीग्राफ
किया था मैसेज बट उसको मैंने रिप्लाई किया
इसके अंदर
उसे नहीं करता हूं मेरा भारतीय
देख लेना देखो रिकॉर्डिंग आपके पास हमेशा
24/7 आपको डेफिनेशन यहां पर मिलेगी मिलेगी
कहां मिलेगी
तो सबसे पहले अपना ये वाला पेज आएगा आपके
सामने ठीक है ना
तो यहां पर आप लाइव
जान के बाद में आपको यहां पर यह दिखाना
देंगे सारे के सारे यहां पर पड़े रहते हैं
मैं रोज एक वीडियो चला कर देखा हूं की
मेरे कमेंट्स कितना है क्या है तो ताकि
मुझे थोड़ा अच्छा लगता है अगर आप लोग
अच्छे से कमेंट करें करते हो मतलब कमेंट
नहीं करोगे तो चलेगा लेकिन आप तक पूरा करो
एकदम मतलब बढ़िया तरीके से ठीक है ना
तो बढ़िया रहेगा
तो आप किसी भी लेक्चर के यहां पर जाओगे
यहां पर अपना
यहां पर आपको हमारे इंस्टाग्राम का ट्विटर
का फेसबुक का हमारा टेलीग्राम का चैनल भी
आप इसको जॉइन कर लो तो आपको सारे भीड़ में
मिलते रहेंगे वेबसाइट